well listen i appreciate you doing this
story i think
you know the big takeaway for me is for
anybody who's an angel investor or an
employee ask questions
you know you were asking before like
employees aren't sophisticated um the
great companies make their employees
sophisticated the great venture firms
like when i was at sequoia
they educated us as the value of stock
options they insisted that we educate
our employees they taught us how to
educate our employees
about when they should exercise or what
the exercise window was
and if you left a company before you
were fully vested and you had an
exercise window
and we had these like really long
discussions you know the other one is
the exercise window i don't know if you
understand that concept when you leave a
company you have 30 days or 60 days
yep and if you have if you're an early
employee even if you're doing like a
penny a share if you've got 10 million
shares this could be serious money
tens of thousands of dollars and a lot
of times employees is the dark secret
employees leave the company
they don't have the money to pay for
private company stock
right and their shares just go back into
the employee stock option pool so
probably a full
one-third or half of employee stock
options never get claimed yeah it's like
a golden handcuff right keeps you there
keeps you there and but the exercise
window i think
you know we had these long conversations
uh when i was a sequoia founder and
other folks about how long that window
should be and i think
all the sophisticated firms want to
build that trust with employees because
you want to compete against facebook
or google or microsoft in the day or
amazon for those employees
so you want them to really understand
that these things could be worth
something and what their strike price is
and what their exercise window is
and now there's a movement to make the
exercise window 10 years
right if you leave uber this was a big
thing with uber
was the exercise where people wouldn't
leave because they didn't want to have
to pay because the price that
it's a high-class problem like this is
only a problem if the company has
appreciated in value significantly which
has only happened
you know one out of a thousand companies
facebook google uber airbnb did you tell
travis that was wrong or you thought
that was wrong
um i don't know if i specifically had
that discussion with him but yeah
you know we travis and i always have
long discussions about right and wrong
and debates of stuff like we i can
remember he's an interesting guy for
sure
the best founders i've ever invested in
are
have a very specific uh
world view that makes them successful
and
they are not going to back down from
that world view without a fight or like
a real debate
and the real debate i had was tipping i
could only remember having two really
deep debates
tipping because i like to tip i'm from
brooklyn and i wanted tipping in the
uber app but yeah he makes a good point
it's it's unfortunate that people are
not paid well enough that you have to
tip that
exactly it should be the opposite he's
not wrong
we discussed and i think if he was still
there he probably would have executed
this way the six star
is how he would describe it to me and so
we brainstormed this of
what if there was a hidden way to give a
tip in uber that was an easter
egg and so the suggestion i gave him was
what if you held the fifth star
for more than three seconds and it
popped up would you like to give a six
star and a tip of this amount
that would have been like the killer
awesome unlock the other thing with
surge pricing which i was wrong about
and he was right about surge pricing
anytime you've been stuck and couldn't
get a car
surge pricing is pretty rad like being
able to get a car in an emergency
situation or
you know on a holiday or something on
thanksgiving or
christmas or new year's like yeah better
to pay 3x then not get it
i think when you do that when you're
buying tickets to the south of france
you know i mean you know when you take
your ship speaks off and yeah
during the high season you know that
business class is triple and yeah
we just deal with these things in the
mirror like put it on the first class
it's the concept it's literally
naval had a good experience where it was
like he you know he's got this little
micro i don't know if you're listening
to naval's like micro podcast naval
ravikont
from angels yeah but i do not know
he does he's like he's got a micro
podcast it's a really clever idea he
just explains one topic for three
minutes or two minutes or five minutes
so you can just you know listen to them
while you're in line at the
you know starbucks or whatever um is
that what twitter is for
sort of and he puts him on twitter but
it's really good because he explains
like one concept and
he just talked about how there are some
people who will pay
a ridiculous amount more for something
that is marginally better and the
example he used was like
a business class or first class ticket
is 50 more space than a coach ticket but
they cost five times as much
so you're getting 50 more value but it
costs five times as much
and the only reason you do that would be
status your ego
or you don't care about money and you
have so much of it that you'll overpay
and in that case it subsidizes the rest
of the plane
the really interesting kind of way of
looking at it yes
all right listen continued success amir
thank you for breaking the news on this
um i it's my sincere hope that this guy
uh
tazzo duvall gets sued into oblivion you
can talk to him too i'm sure he'll talk
to you
i don't think he's going to talk to me
because i am wailing on him he's
definitely not going to talk to me and i
think this guy's a coward you might be
surprised
i think he's a coward for doing this um
i think
the right thing to do here to sow
duvall if you're listening just convert
to equity
get be a mensch do what you're supposed
to not even be a match just
be a basic human being give your
employees
basic stop options and if you're
thinking of going to work for this
company or you're thinking about using
them
to build your app you've got to get your
head examined anybody who would screw
their co-founder their employees
and their investors the people who
supported them to get where they are
anybody who would do that
is going to screw you eventually that's
for future employees future investors in
future
users of top towel do not use top tile
service until they
clear this up he should just it's such a
such bad reputation what
did you talk to him yeah i did actually
he called you
how long did it take you to get him on
the phone i'm curious well i actually
talked to him
before i knew what the story was going
to be
and then came back to him later it was
an email conversation he was not pleased
um i i don't i don't think he's pleased
um i um yeah it's interesting the the
original
interview yeah uh it's hard to see the
original interview
was recorded by him which i agreed to
only on the condition that he also gave
me the recording which i still do not
have
um but uh you should have recorded it
yourself yeah
yeah uh you didn't have to have your
phone set up for that because it's
illegal in san fran
in california to record that right on a
phone two parties yeah yeah yeah you
have to you have to get it
new york you don't it's a new york
journalist no he yes yes yes yes and i
said
i said sure just give me give me a copy
um he has a very interest
we didn't talk about how colorful he is
and maybe we'll leave that for the story
but
he has a very interesting idea of what
intellectual property is
and that includes uh personnel
changes at his company so for instance
if his co-founder leaves the company
but hasn't announced it publicly uh he
he takes that uh he believes that that
is not
necessarily something that somebody else
like me should be talking about which is
where he wants to sue you no no no no no
no for stealing their ipads i don't know
it's just
it's it's a failed threat he's you know
this is his baby
right and he treats it as such and so
it's very
you know everything about it is very
sensitive and i think um uh but but
again he's in
he's large and in charge so there's no
is this person there's no there's no
pressure on him there's no pressure on
him
to do anything different because he has
created a very successful entity that's
my point
i think he's going to get sued into
oblivion and i think that when they do
discovery he's gonna realize like
screwing people over
it only takes like one or two people you
screw over to really dig in like
if i was one of these employees i would
create a revenge startup
and i would just go right after take all
the employees because that's fair game
and you know just gut the place and give
them equity
that's how i got peter rojas by the way
do you know that story no i don't know
that story
so nick denton promised
um peter rojas equity okay in
um gizmodo okay okay i pursued him in
elizabeth spires or spears
spires i think spires say i pronounce it
anyway
elizabeth wanted to go work for new york
magazine peter i told him i'll double
whatever
nick denton's paying you and i'll give
you equity
and uh you'll be worth millions of
dollars 18 months later
he was worth millions of dollars we sold
the company aol right on but it was like
that was literally my recruit to him was
denton will never give you equity he's
avoided this conversation five times he
promised he never did it he's never
going to do it
yeah and then after that denton started
giving equity to employees and papering
it
i don't think it was became worth
anything after the lawsuit but uh so
your point is integrity matters
i think yeah if you're going to do a
deal like this and you want to use
equity as an incentive
you kind of got to live up to that and i
think tasso knows that he screwed
everybody
he knows he screwed everybody he says
it's all legal read your read your
documents read your contract
yeah that's the lowest form of ethics
is when people say it's not illegal like
it might not be illegal to stalk
somebody
to a certain point or harass somebody
that doesn't mean
it's ethical or moral like there's
there's a large number of people who
have done completely unethical immoral
things who did not go to jail for them
like
the long list and i i can i am just in
shock of
the thing that makes no sense here is
he could give 10 to the employees 17
to his co-founder and 15 to
the investors right that's 40
or so he would still own 58 of the
company
right those people would be on his side
rooting for him motivated and the
company would become worth more than 40
percent
and in fact the company did become what
it's worth because those people believed
in him and trusted him and gave him that
money and gave them their time
in exchange for equity and he abused it
and now i'm getting pissed off again
i'll let you have the last word
damn it i'm pissed off again i am sorry
i i just
ugh it's a good story read the story
everyone uh everybody read the story
everybody subscribe to the information
and follow amir
a-m-i-r